hi I'm Ali hi i'm colin and this is our
hot dog wedding
colin is 8 years old he grew up in color
texas ali also 28 was born two weeks
after me
grew up in tulsa oklahoma there was an
Oscar Mayer wiener jingle contest at her
elementary school that I'm sure you
tried your hardest away in dead but did
not did not but she also grew up eating
Oscar Mayer Weiner and we eat them today
we both went to the University of
Oklahoma
I saw Colin an elevator after one of our
classes and I like knew that he lived
downstairs I got in the elevator he like
gets in and I was like oh God and I
didn't talk to him and I knew that I
loved him and that moment our friends
got married last year and I hijacked
their wedding brunch to propose to Ali
the next day shocker
dearly beloved we are gathered here
today for the most unbelievable wedding
you'll ever attend in your life very
important that I stress that this is an
incredibly unique hot dog wedding but it
is still a wedding and a wedding at its
core is a time to stop look at two
beautiful people and say hey something
meaningful is happening right now so
let's focus on this and celebrate it I
love that Ali stays true to who she is
no matter what and she knows who she is
and she's proud of that and so am i
mm-hmm I knew from the moment that I saw
you that I had to know you and it
humbles me that I had been fortunate
enough to build such a rewarding
intricate life with you over the last
eight years be your wife o be one of the
greatest honors of my life I just feel
so lucky that
once to hang out with me haunt I'm sorry
so today in front of all of our friends
and family and the leaner God still
never hold back again and I will tell
you how much I love you every time do I
feel it starting now rings
[Laughter]
that's how you do it folks
now with the promises to each other in
mind Colin do you take Ali to be your
wife do you promise to love her for
better or for worst an ally with the
promises to each other in mind
do you take Colin to be your husband do
you promise to love him for better or
for worse so by the power vested in me
by the state of hotdogs I now pronounce
you husband and wife
kiss each other yeah I don't know whose
idea this was but this is our one and
only wedding and it is becoming more
than we ever it like giving us a wedding
that we we started about in a
non-traditional wedding and you can't
get more no less traditional than been a
weiner wedding
[Music]
my one hope is that at the end of the
night as we're walking out everyone has
a drink and a hot dog in their hands
yeah just like a nice cheers and a bite
before we ride off into the sunset
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]